start with a non-alcoholic first before
I get jump right starting off with
non-alcoholic start with a non-alcoholic
starting off with non-alcoholic it's
harder to go back G I'm going to have a
I'm going to start with an alcoholic and
then if I feel like going non-alcoholic
I'll go nonalcoholic I'm being judged
okay fine you successfully pess yes
let's go fine it's the end of year right
it's it's that ASMR it's the end of the
year although to be fair to be fair
credit credits to Cheers Cheers Cheers
ever since uh our last conversation
about non-alcoholic beer I have been a
conver converted you yeah bro I'm
telling it's actually fire like Japan is
Japan has really been stepping it up
with the non-alcoholic options and um to
the point now where you know if it's a
night where I'm going to have like one
or two beers yeah I'll just stay with
the non-alcoholics I'm like what's the
point I don't know I haven't got to the
point where I can just drink beer for
The Taste yet I [__] love the taste
of beer it's it's I don't like alcohol I
like the taste of beer but not enough to
justify see it's not just about the
taste because I I remember last time
when I we had this conversation made the
argument that you know it just doesn't
taste the same which it doesn't but for
me it's the feeling of having a pint
that's that's what I'm saying you you
laugh at it
you do you know what it is I'm still
saying that you know do you know what it
is it's it's not even the taste it's the
it's the foaminess of it you know it's
it's it's the gassiness that you only
get with uh kind of like beer drink some
[__] mineral water bro no CU if I
actually do and I just doesn't hit the
same if you ever get into beer right
like there is this ultimate moment of
peak refreshness when you've had a day
that you felt like [__] that took it out
of me you cracked that c open and you
take that first sip full foam full
coldness it's every every Peak moment of
the beer and you're like oh yeah but I'm
happy to know that like taking that
first sip which I totally get is the
best feeling ever especially when it's
like stupid stinking hot in a Japanese
summer right like that that first ice
cold can of beer is the best but I also
like the fact that oh I'm going to get a
little bit loopy from it as well well
you know well it's sometimes I don't
know if I don't want to get drunk I'll
just crack open a mineral I normally
don't get drunk though I normally
maintain like the nice Buzz level which
beer helps me do wa what's wrong with
that though well no that's not drunk
though I wouldn't say it's drunk it's
just me being like a little funny and do
you not like getting buzzed uh no I like
getting buzzed yeah yeah yeah that's fun
but so I'm trying to figure out what's
what's the justification nonalcoholic
well because I don't always want to get
that I can I I think I do it a little
bit different from Connor because for me
sometimes I mean this goes back to I
guess when I was working the office job
as well sometimes you just have a really
[__] hard day of work sure and you
just want to sit back relax and crack
open a cold one I just said
that I literally just said that no
because he he was he was saying about
the taste right for me well it's like
that's part of the experience there as
well to me like the taste you know but
it's mainly about Jesus you've had one
sip Jo no it's mainly about like having
the long day and then getting that like
first Sip and it's like a very nice
feeling and beer has a texture which is
important in food
uh it's a very nice texture that kind of
just is I don't know it's perfect I
don't know no to expand on what you were
saying like before um it's the feeling
and
also sometimes you just want to crack
open a pint after a hard day of work
without needing to get like the
consequence of getting drunk or yeah but
do you feel the consequences after one
pint well no okay so this is great this
is a great great argument um that uh cuz
I'm I'm ready uh a beer like this beer
would be like 250 calories 200 calories
right not that I'm counting calories
right but I'm you know I want to be in
shape right so I'm I'm thinking to
myself what I can kind of roughly eat
I'm I don't count calories to the
[__] number but I'm thinking in my
head of like the rough toll of what I've
been eating sure and so if I have like
two beers or you know that's like a a
full like small lunch or a snack that I
could have eaten instead um they call
beers liquid meals for a reason yeah I
mean it's it's definitely the Cobbs are
killing man there so many Cobbs
especially if you're doing it weekly
right because if you have one beer like
four times a week I have a solution then
that's like a th000 calories I have a
solution uh don't drink beer but I I
don't get the same refreshment and
enjoyment from like a m you got to
sacrifice one or the other well that's
why I I I I we're sacrificing the
alcohol we're safing which is the worst
thing you could be sacrificing wait it's
The scientifically the best thing you
can don't sacrifice the [__] caffeine
in a coffee do you I wouldn't mind doing
that oh my God he's too far gone bro oh
you getting into decaf now he's too far
gone bro the reason why I'm never we
lost him the reason why I'm never going
to get into decaf and this is a very
piss poor reason but I think it's valid
yeah you know I've got a I've got a
coffee machine and it takes a bunch of
beans if I I would have to like take out
I would have to take out all the beans
and replace them every time I want decaf
I I can't hear you say beans without
hearing you say it beans what the
[__] I don't want to I don't want to
[__] have to change the entire
[__] machine to drink get decaf but
well that's what you get for having
having a [__] off [__] off large machine
uh yeah but it's a beautiful machine
it's it's the centerpiece of my
house you have what the [__] Lego
piece on your wall I've got a beautiful
Italian engineered espresso machine all
the engineering points of Italy went
into coffee they they can't make
anything else in Italy literally they
they don't have anything else but they
have poer is crying
right in like engineering wise right
Germany they they did it everything it
was like well um expresso machines
anyone can't even build a [__] Tower
correctly no they can't it's
leing just like what the [__] man have
you ever seen a completed Italian Road
Works doesn't exist never seen it how's
your [__] cities go oh they're
sinking oh okay that's good to know
Italy has like every single economic
crisis possible right now but my God
they still make a mean espresso machine
and their food [__] slaps their food
is amazing um point being so yeah they
they kind of spec their points to the
correct categories no it's fine honestly
I'm sure it looks lovely mean
machine it's all right I I took that
personally oh sorry I'm not sorry no but
because of the non-alcoholic bit I was
like I saw there was a store selling
non-alcoholic wine as well and there you
know I'm a big I think that's called
grap juice and I was like I know this is
going to be grape juice but maybe
because this cuz I've realized
non-alcohol non-alcoholic beer is
basically just hop flavored sparkling
water so maybe they've just made kind of
like cuz wine is great juice obviously
but it doesn't always taste like grape
juice you know yeah it tastes like Lo of
aspects
to maybe they made water taste like beer
without having the alcohol in it maybe
they've done the same with wine I just
bought [__] grape juice but they
marked it up to like $15 bought
expensive grap ju I just bought really
[__] expensive grape juice I've never
been more disappointed in my life this
is what's wrong with Society I got
invited out to this extremely fancy
resturant and I it was an Italian
restaurant and I was like you know I I
love Italian food but this was like Giga
Bouie fusion and when I hear Fusion food
in my head I'm like okay so they're just
G to [__] it up um cuz pasta you know
pasta is just pasta you know what I mean
like I I feel like Fusion's coming back
I think some fusion works but Italian is
one of those things where I'm like
actually don't Fusion it they actually
figured it out please stop messing with
it the it's cu the word Fusion was just
ruined by all of these restaurants that
just the word Fusion just to say that
they want yeah that's just say serve
every kind of Southeast asan you know I
went to this thae Japanese fusion and I
thought that was great because that was
literally just adding spices to Japanese
food because in Japan it's it's all just
salt which is fine but they added like
spiciness to it I was like wait this is
like you guys should do this like this
is this is great but I went to this time
when it was very good but the reason I
bring this up is because they had a
non-alcoholic wine pairing menu and I
didn't want to drink that day so I was
like okay sure I'll try it um and and to
be fair to their credit I don't even
want to know how much it would cost I
didn't pay um that's why you did it um
there was no prices on the menu which
meant everything I didn't even want to
know everything came out and it was this
big which I think goes against the
entire point of Italian food I'm
supposed to I'm supposed to feel
morbidly obese after going to an Italian
that's the American side of you uh well
no I just think Italian food you should
feel very full like it's it's a very
well you do because a lot of it is very
C that's that's the fusion part of it
Fus and then the fusion they they
fusioned all the food away so because
pesta was like this and the guy brought
it out and I said where's the rest of it
think that the guy couldn't speak
English and he goes what and I said ah
nothing nothing anyway they brought this
this non fused every single dish came
with a non-alcoholic wine pairing thing
and they were like it was like Jasmine
uh one of them was like Jasmine flower
petals with something it was yeah and it
was kind of okay I I felt like it was
good enough that for a meal I would be I
would be like yeah that's close enough
but it was missing at the call feeling
of wine whereas I think nonalc
non-alcoholic beer has kind of gotten
the the core feeling of beer so question
would you if you had if you were paying
for that restaurant experience would you
have gotten that non-alcoholic
wine oh did you did you do it because
you seize the opportunity of getting it
trying it out like free of charge it was
just super fancy juice that was slightly
viscous and like which is fine cuz I
think that like that that that's also
like an option I think that like I think
any any time you can present an option
that doesn't have alcohol we should be
encouraging that because obviously the
less alcohol we all drink the better um
so if if you can get it like if wine
tasted the exact same but with no
alcohol bro I'm I'm all there you know
what I mean yeah you can't say that in
front of a [__] sea of alcohol but
that's the thing I maybe maybe in 60
years you know uh Conor junor will be
able to enjoy all the flavors of
non-alcoholic beer without needing to
drink alcohol look look I'm not calling
him Conor Jun by here's the thing here
for the here's the problem okay I like
getting drunk sure I don't like the
consequence of getting drunk you know
that's that's something that you did not
have to deal with in your 20s and then
you grow up and then you realize wait
there are consequences for the stupid
actions that I take and it's unfortunate
that Japan is a very very alcoholic
country yeah we love to drink well so is
England and so is Australia and I
thought England was pretty England and
the UK was bad in general you know and I
felt that in the UK it was more so I
would drink on weekends and I would
drink hard on the weekends but in Japan
what I found is is that you drink hard
but it'll be a Tuesday and then a a
Thursday and then a Friday and a
Saturday and you're like okay hold up
now I'm doubling what I was doing before
reality really doesn't slap you in the
face here until you witness a Sho
meltdown for with your own eyes you know
there was just so much more casual
alcohol consumption here and to more of
an extent than so much cheaper as well
like it's so cheap eat out way more here
as well so it's totally like if you're
in England you if you go out um if you
just casually go to a pub then you
probably an alcoholic you know
but or a brex Giza or or a brexit Giza
like if you just casually go to the pub
on most week days you're probably an
alcoholic how we made how we like coped
with that was we were like we just drink
on the weekends we guys what alcohol we
just drink the weekend that's how we
cope with it I think that as a human
being you are entitled to
self-destruction um as long as you're
not hurting anyone else if you want to
drink on the weekends and that's your
thing [__] do it if if it's affecting
other people then you got a [__]
aggress yeah and then like that was
before I started Workforce and then when
I entered the workforce it's it slowly
started to creep in to be like today was
a hard day of work and some of my
co-work that's like the dangerous that's
where like the line like between uh my
first example and my second example
that's how you tiptoe the line um so I
kind of realized the sad realization
that stuff like this helps us [__]
tiptoe that
line right yeah it is nice I mean it's
yeah yeah I have a feeling though that
you guys have kind of reached this point
probably because you both of you drink
more often than I
do I don't drink at home I I don't think
I've drank in like over a week at least
for me and like I only maybe drink like
two or three times a month so I feel
like the more you drink the more I might
start to feel like this month this month
particularly is generally a bad one this
one this month is oh don't worry next
week I'm in Australia I'm not going to
have a sober day well yeah it's like
when my when my brother was here you
know it's his vacation right so when I'm
out with him he to drink and I you know
and I'm like yeah [__] it I'll drink
with my brother I don't get to see you
that much the problem is that when you
think about times like that you're like
okay my brother is here he's here for
like one week every [__] three years
or something i''s say it's like I'm
going to commit to that but the context
is that okay maybe the week before that
I also just happen to drink a lot and
then now I'm drinking all week and then
maybe I drink a little bit next week too
so it ends up being like it doesn't
matter what the circumstances the facts
are is that maybe I just drank a bunch
this day and then I'm just trying to
battle that this is uh yeah this is
aounds
slowly starting sound to sound like
alcohol like Anonymous or is right but
this is what happens when I realized I
was like the consequences of having a
social life in Japan yeah because Japan
social life equals drink but I mean you
know I lately I've just been saying like
you know if I know it's going to be like
CU some people just invite you out for a
casual dinner and I'm like chill [__]
yeah they'll drink and I'm like actually
no I'm just I'm just going to [__]
drink tea [__] this I just to me I'm
like if I'm not going to have like four
beers I'm like [__] but we also like I
feel like Japanese culture as well is is
an one because even though we drink so
much like casually regardless of the day
of the week we're also more forgiving to
those who don't want to drink or can't
drink just because I feel there's a lot
more people who just cannot drink right
so like it's it's it's very odd because
I it depends on the person though as
well I've definitely met you having
people that are like you don't want to
drink what yeah that to them I'd be like
[__] off it's my choice stop judging me
whereas in Australia like if you
couldn't drink like you were you know in
some ways judged and I'm sure the same
in the UK as well
drinking culture is such AAL culture
over there that you see someone who
drink ores want to drink then it's kind
like Muslims must have been watching
this first half of the show being like
what are they talking what are they what
are they talking about that sounds like
some funny juice that they're drinking
right now devil yeah because like I
every time it always kind of like makes
me realize whenever I talk to an
American and so many Americans I know it
depends on obviously which state you're
from but so many Americans I know don't
know the difference I like I've had to
explain the difference between going out
and going out out if if if you guys get
what I mean like going out like the
first one just being like oh we're just
going to go maybe have a couple of yeah
like a casual drink Cas time not drunk
and then there going out yeah yeah so
sometimes sometimes to explain sometimes
you go out with your mates to the to the
pub or something and you just have a
casual some casual drinks and on some
special occasions Maybe the vibe is just
right you have you start getting to that
zone where you're like should we should
we go out out are we going to are we
going to go out out this is a UK
specific problem though because often
like if you have to like kind of pregame
yeah normally that means like okay well
there's this this pivotal decision
moment yeah where people are going to
decide let's keep going or let's go but
in Japan I feel like it's such those
lines are so blurred because you're
always out in Japan yeah so you're
always close to the next place or the
next bar do you know one thing that I
like about Japan culture what they don't
really have a shot culture here oh thank
[__] for
that if you drink with Pete Pete finds
the places with shot culture well he's
American though yeah I know but he just
you know he's he's too charismatic he
gets the bar owners involved and they're
like oh you should drink more you need
to go to those like specific
establishments though right but you know
what sucks is that when I tell people
they're like they're like how how did
you how did you learn most of Japanese
I'm like [__] I hate to admit it but
like just going out and drinking was
most of it for me honestly that go to
these bars and talking to Bar owners you
know and they're so welcoming especially
if you're a if you're a foreigner who
speaks uh some Japanese that you know
they and they can kind of see that that
that normally that huge barrier is kind
of gone there's normally this kind of
curiosity that kind of opens up where
you can really just have a really good
conversation because they want to talk
to you and you want to talk to them
because you're you know you're at their
bar and you want to get to know the the
places cuz I think everyone everyone has
that like especially if you're going to
a place somewhat often you always want
to be like does that guy remember me
like I want to be I want to be like this
guy he's like yeah it's this guy again
you know because you want it it's like
almost like a sense of community right
cuz in Jaan you don't you don't get that
in a lot of places if I went to the same
you're the local Gan at this far but
like if I went to the same like uh
grocery store for like two years in a
row in the UK there's a solid chance at
least in Wales if it's a smaller one if
it's a supermarket probably not but if
it's like a smaller one right odds are
you'll the staff will probably remember
you or they'll probably say oh hi how
you doing you know you have that little
bit of conversation just kind of like
that that you don't realize how much it
kind of like gives you a bit of like oh
man that's ni nice and the only place
you can really get this in Japan is bars
because like comini they ain't going to
[__] it you can go to the comini 5
million times and they're never going to
be say anything to you it's not going to
happen store no I've been recognized by
a number of comini well okay but is that
is that I I I got to go I got it you got
it girl I got I got to hook up but like
that's an anomaly right like that's like
not normal right so in in Japan like if
you want to get like that kind of
friendly sense of like almost like
almost like a missing sense of community
well I think it also doesn't help that
like we are in like the biggest city in
the [__] world other cities on Earth
don't do this I noticed London was
different like London I know if I went
to the same place over and over again I
would kind of get that familiar
connection but but that's because
they're more they have more of that
stranger friendliness right like in
Tokyo that stranger friendliness is
close to zero especially between a
Japanese post and a g Tokyo is such a
lonely place and it has this reputation
rightfully so for being one of the
loneliest cities despite being a [__]
giant City uh because there is that like
there's like zero sense of community in
a lot places into like any kind of store
in Tokyo is like just the same
interaction over and over it's like it's
like entering the item shop in an RPG
you know like you're going to get the
same dialogue every single time even if
you've been in there a 100 times yeah
but you know I like that in Japan you
can still get that but it's mainly at
bars it's kind of nice cuz I got a bunch
of bars that I go to where they're
always like oh how you doing man you
doing well well I feel like it's kind of
their job to be social right or at least
more Social cuz I think they realize
that that's also a good business move
right to get repeaters coming back right
at least you are a good me I mean it's
it's makes a lot of places that I um
I've noticed they are just genuinely
nice genuinely nice and just genuinely
enjoy the company and enjoy the
conversation and they are genuinely
curious also I would like to say earlier
when I say I got a girl I was [__]
being sarcastic it's like an old elderly
Japanese woman um so you got a girl I
got a girl got a girl bro she's still a
girl I was like I I and she works like
okay so there's this old elderly
Japanese woman and she normally works
The Late Shift right so I normally hit
the comy after like a trash taste
recording or something and there was
this one time where I went in it was
really late after a night out uh and
there was his Foreigner there and she
was trying to explain some uh she was
trying to
explain uh explain how to use like the
card system and stuff like that and he
just wasn't [__] getting it and she
was she was
like and she was like can you explain to
this person what I'm saying and I was
like all right I got this I got this um
and uh yeah so I translated I translated
what she was saying to him to explain
how to use the machine he was trying to
use uh and then ever since then she's
just like she's just been like extra
like friendly and happy every time we
come in I'm like all right I got to go
now that's what's up I got to go now so
next time you go in you'll be like hey
yo can I have some of that free chicken
do so you got any free going go to waste
if you don't give it to me my local
comity they look miserable
I don't blame them they do it's I it is
a rough comini it does not look good at
at our old place uh up in you know up
north like there was the comany worker
near our house like later at night who
just used to give me free chicken every
time I walked in he was just like we got
some we're going to throw it out do you
want I'm like sure hey are you the anime
man do you want a free chicken he
recognized you right yeah he recognized
me and then he was like oh you want some
free chicken I'm like okay I wish it was
that easy Joey I know what I say I wish
I could be that famous to
wish it was I wish it was lens then I'd
be interested in the free
chicken yeah family Mar chicken get that
[__] out of here